نقلت وسائل اعلام وواليه للنظام السوري ان
الطيران التركي نفذ خمس غارات على مواقع
لما تعرفوا بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في
قريه المكمل شرق نهر الفرات بريفي دير
الزور والتي تبعد قرابه 80 كلم عن الحدود
مع تركيا وافادت مصادر محليه ومواقع
مواليه ان اربعه عناصر من هذه القوات
قتلوا وجرح خمسه اخرون بينهم قيادي بقصف
مسيرات تركيه لمواقعهم في كل من تل زيوان
بريف القامشلي وقاعده مشتركه للتحالف
الدولي شمالا الحسكه وموقعيين نفطيين في
القحطانيه بريف الحسكه بالاضافه الى قريه
العوجا التابعه لتلتمر من جهتها قالت
مصادر في المعارضه السوريه ان قصفا تركيا
استاذه مواقع لسوريا ديمقراطيه في محيط
التل رفعت ومصاري وريفي منبج بري في حلب
بينما ردت هذه القوات بقصر في عييتين
تركييتين بريف حلب الشمالي
وقد افادت مصادر محليه في شمال سوريا
بمقتل عنصرين مما يعرف مما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه جراء قصف تركيا على احد
المواقع في تلي زيوان بريف القامشلي كما
افاد مراسل الجزيره نقلا عن مصادر في
المعارضه بتعرض مواقع ما يعرف بقوات سوريا
ديموقراطيه في محيط تل رفعه بريف حلب الى
قصف تركيا وقال انما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قصفت بعده قذائف قاعده تركيه
في قريه كالجبرين بريفي حلب